Charles may be head of the monarchy but
his spare is king of Book Sales now two
days after the release of Prince Harry's
bombshell Memoir the royal family steps
out
William kept up a united front with Kate
in Liverpool today ignoring questions
about Harry's Memoir a royal Insider
tells E.T that the Princess of Wales was
hurt and disappointed that private
matters had been made public King
Charles he looked upbeat in a Tartan
Kilt making several stops in Scotland
Stephen uh not not needed but thank you
I appreciate it there's been so much
hype around this book over in England
the whole country is mad at Harry the
Cowboys stopped this Royal Circus the
book is 36 so it's quite an amount to
cough up spare has sold more than 1.4
million copies in the U.S Canada and
Britain but as part of it fiction
Harry's Ghostwriter is now defending
what he calls inadvertent mistakes in
the Memoir among them Harry asserts that
he was at boarding school when he found
out about the queen mother's death in
2002 according to multiple reports he
was actually on a ski trip with his
father and there's this claim about
Megan's Dad we told him to leave Mexico
right now a whole new level of
harassment is about to rain down on you
Air New Zealand first class booked and
paid for by Meg turns out Air New
Zealand says it has never operated
flights between Mexico and the UK and it
does not offer first class Harry's
Ghostwriter says the line between memory
and fact is blurry
[Music]